didn't you make amends with a whole
bunch of people didn't you get some kind
of spirituality recently so yeah when
everybody started dying around me I'm
looking I'm older than these guys you
know and I just thought you know I don't
want to take any enemies to the grave
why in the world would you want to take
an enemy to the grave if there is an
afterlife and didn't have to deal with
it later but lunge no luggage should who
did you pick up the phone and call well
I tried to get a hold of Eddie was the
first guy sent him a happy birthday
message and and in that debt - that's
big of you
yeah well it's okay as long as I feel
good about it like okay I'm I don't I
don't I'm not mad at you I'm not mad at
anybody you know would you apologize to
him no I was will I was I wanted to
apologize for I well I don't know what
did you do wrong well for for making
them feel insecure somehow whatever I
did you did something I did something I
don't know what I did but I'm with you
on that one but but no but I'm not mad
at them for any reason but my point is
is that I invited and Nell over in my
house recently oh I did it was around
Al's birthday no kid I wrote him an
email and I called Irving Azoff is it
Irving give me a house email I want to
and invite him and Ed over with they're
wise and just to have a no agenda just
to be friends and I didn't even get a
response but it's okay really yeah but I
I'm Michael you shocked I am shocked
down the road from Sam and I didn't
invite him I said Mike he lives that's
what happens into that close to somebody
Michael didn't you have a conversation
with Alex Van Halen two years ago it was
actually probably about two three years
ago and it's just out of the blue of a
mutual friend of ours came to visit
visit me where I live and he said hey he
told Alex I was that we were together
and we talked we talked for about maybe
15-20 minutes nothing about music or
anything just about life just about life
and how are you doing how's the family
Oh crazy it is I love those guys I mean
I don't want to be back that band I
swear to god I love this band right here
I mean yeah you got a good life it's all
good exactly I don't need you you do
have a good band and yeah
happy yeah but I would like to be
friends